I think I misused my powers.
Where are we?
It looks like we're inside somewhere
crazy, but I don't know where, and
I forgot my phone.
Wait, I have an idea.
I can use the Google Geolocation API
to figure out where I am.
The Geolocation API is useful for
devices or
machines that don't already have
Geolocation built in natively.
Devices that run on Unix,
Linux, TinyOS, RIOT or
other operating systems might have
a need to know their location.
There are plenty of machines
in the Internet of Things.
A giant network of internet enabled
devices that qualify for this.
The Google Geolocation API,
provides a web service they can
use to get location information.
They can pass information
from cell towers or
WiFi nodes, to the Geolocation API,
to get back the location and
accuracy radius on where the device is.
It's the perfect API for
detecting location indoors, or
when GPS is weak or unavailable.
For example, the giant particle
accelerator behind me,
if it's internet enabled,
could tell me that I'm in France at
the [FOREIGN], also known as CERN.
But I probably shouldn't be here,
so let's move on.
[SOUND] Oops, my bad.
Still trying to get
a hang of this thing.
While I practice, let's take
a look at what we've done so far.
[SOUND]